[Música]
a
época
a observar mas o passado da humanidade
podemos perceber que assim como Existem
muitos avanços tantas outras angústias
permanecem latentes à importância da
natureza na nossa qualidade de vida e
como nos relacionamos com essa natureza
Apesar de todas as nossas diferenças nós
temos um futuro que é comum todos nós
vivenciamos aqui este planeta em
territórios que são conectados senão
através da terra do ar que respiramos
das águas que fluem no trem nosso solo e
do Sol que emite sua energia ah e hoje
mais do que nunca Vivemos em cidades
Alguns de nós vivem pequena cidade
outros médias mas a grande maioria de
nós e os grandes centros urbanos
os aglomerados urbanos
na década de 90 2015 a população urbana
mundial cresceu cerca de 1,9 vezes nesse
mesmo período as áreas urbanizadas
cresceram cerca de 2,5 vezes mais do que
duplicaram de tamanho em relação à
década anterior a 90 dados segundo o ato
de expansão urbana do habitar há
previsões de que as áreas urbanas
seguiram crescendo
esses dados são muito importantes ao
refletirmos sobre as oportunidades que
podem ser geradas sem perder de vista os
impactos que estão relacionados nesse
processo de construção de cidades
modificamos os ambientes naturais em
ambientes artificiais
geralmente retiramos a cobertura vegetal
do solo modifica a cozinha depois
impactando na biodiversidade no
microclima local nesse processo de
condução cidades também afastamos as
áreas de produção de alimentos dos seus
consumidores
consumimos muitos produtos insumos e
tecnologias e também emitimos muitos
influentes liberamos muitos resíduos
para a natureza isso no processo de
construção como de operação das cidades
EA natureza quando existe permanece em
fragmentos áreas residuais em pequenos
espaços na nossa cidades muitas vezes
longe das áreas de convivência esses
impactos
correlacionados podem gerar problemas de
caráter sistêmico a título de exemplo
desses problemas de caráter sistema as
áreas impermeabilizadas
que modificam os recursos hídricos do
solo através da comissão de edifícios e
áreas pavimentadas
a mente diminui a infiltração das águas
nos solos aumentando a pressão os
sistemas de drenagem Urbana que pode
gerar inundações as enchentes essas
enchentes geralmente atinge muitas
pessoas E para piorar o cenário as
pessoas em situação de vulnerabilidade
social são as mais atingidas
esse processo de transformação de
ambientes naturais em ambientes
artificiais também pagam desempenho
energético das cidades ao construir o
edifício sobrepostos uns aos outros
modificamos e aumentamos a ilha de calor
Urbano interferindo no microclima local
isso gera a sensação de conforto o que
aumenta Nossa necessidade de consumo de
energia um dado. Perverso observaremos
que os edifícios são responsáveis por
cerca de cinquenta por cento da energia
produzida
e no Brasil aí conforme dados do da
empresa de energia do Brasil
e ainda esse processo de construção de
edifícios altos sem considerar as áreas
verdes o ar que pode fluir pela cidades
pode gerar sombras Profundas
especialmente lutar no lugar onde
vivenciamos as idades fatores esses que
podem aumentar a proliferação de umidade
que gera patologias nas construções
aumentando nossos gastos de manutenção
mas especialmente
impacta na nossa saúde o sol é essencial
para nossa energia Vital
percebam que esses impactos
correlacionados causam danos sobrepostos
difíceis de mensurar no sistema social e
econômico
por isso que a dinâmica da
sustentabilidade pensa nas relações
entre aspectos sociais ambientais e
econômicos e essa visão sistêmica a que
predomina está recorrente nos debates
das organizações internacionais
e inclusive o último Fórum de
desenvolvimento econômico a ponto as
mudanças climáticas a segurança
alimentar a qualidade da água dos
problemas relacionados à saúde humana
como sendo os principais riscos dos
negócios nas cidades mas como podemos
mitigar esses impactos ou melhor como
podemos pensar em criar cidades mais
sustentáveis mais saudáveis e abundantes
e felizes para todos ao contrário do que
podemos imaginar ao observar esses dados
impactos relacionados a cidade São
lugares pensados para um ambiente de
trocas e convivência humana portanto são
os espaços apropriados para aprendizagem
colaborativa para que a diversidade
humana possa correlacionar suas visões e
juntos podemos aprender Soluções
nós sabemos que Temos que preservar a
natureza Mas precisamos ir além
precisamos regenerar a natureza
precisamos compreender a natureza da
cidade EA natureza na cidade isso
significa entender a natureza humana e
as suas formas de apropriação do espaço
esse pensamento de relacionar os
elementos da natureza com os elementos
construídos na cidade
pensar em transições mais suaves entre o
natural eo construído precisa ser
considerado em todas as escalas de
abrangência da cidade desde a escala do
ambiente interno a escala do edifício e
suas relações com seu entorno a escala
da rua do bairro da cidade e dos
aspectos regionais relacionados portanto
a medidas as soluções que precisam ser
pensadas na direção da construção de
cidades sustentáveis
pensando na formulação de estratégias e
planos urbanos Empreendimentos e
negócios e na direção da
sustentabilidade social ambiental e
econômica soluções sim que demandam de
investimento de caráter público e
privado políticas públicas mas existem
soluções que podem deve ser pensado na
escala local sintam a importância da sua
pele o lugar que resguarda seu coração o
seu corpo a nossa segunda pele são
nossas roupas nossas vestimentas que
mudam conforme o dia a dia e questões
pessoais
nossa casa o nosso lar é como Nossa
terceira pele nos nossos ambientes de
lugar os espaços que nós vivenciamos as
idades Nossa espaços de lazeres São como
Nossa quarta pele
percebam o quanto esses lugares
interfere na qualidade de vida no seu
cotidiano e como esses espaços se
relacionam com a natureza
esse lugar que tinha influencia É também
um lugar que você pode influenciar
as ações de interferências na
micropaisagem lá na sua casa enfim o seu
ambiente de negócio um espaço perdido na
sua rua quem sabe podemos plantar alguma
vegetação essas espécies podem ser
comestíveis e nos fornecer uma
alimentação saudável podem ser
expectativas a fauna e contribuir para a
biodiversidade
podemos também com postar os nossos
resíduos sólidos orgânicos que vai
contribuir para diminuição do impacto
desses resíduos na escala da cidade e
também para quem trabalha com a
separação desses resíduos Os catadores
por exemplo percebam que assim podemos
como criar ciclos contínuos e
permanentes
regenerando Nossa cultura e
proporcionando ciclos pra economia
solidária esse processo de transição de
espaços naturais com os espaços
construídos obviamente não é medida
suficiente para
a todos os impactos com relacionados Às
nossas cidades
tão pouco existem padrões universais de
interferência nas nossas cidades que vão
garantir a sustentabilidade social
ambiental e econômica existem muitas
incertezas mas temos como certeza as
possibilidades de cocriação de um mundo
melhor e podemos pensar e criar soluções
nas cidades para além das tecnologias
para Além das pessoas podemos pensar e
criar recriar cidades considerando todos
os seres de todas as idades raças e
cores
e portanto Somos Todos co-responsáveis
Pela transformação EA Regeneração das
nossas culturas e da natureza dentro e
fora de nós gratidão por seguirmos
juntos a transformar o mundo em um lugar
melhor e